Britain maybe the Isle of sandwiches but
it's also the land of upscale lunches
British workers spend an average of
three thousand five hundred euros
annually for lunch and snacks as people
hate to eat the same thing all the time
I bought some smoked salmon and some
vegetables today there's more choice so
this is Italian from down yet it's very
group and on the excellent yeah salad
with a tuna tuna fish for salmon pretty
possible I don't mind it's a beef and
vegetable pasta people have higher
expectations these days of lunch
leftover lasagna from last night's
dinner no longer cuts the mustard a
spate of cookbooks have recently
appeared to meet the demand for gourmet
lunches and snacks one is love your
lunch box by James ramsden it recommends
such delectable recipes as the three
cheese toastie with spinach and chili
jam or chickpeas with mango chutney the
london-based chef sees a growing demand
for such food I think people certainly
are a lot more conscious about what they
because they're constantly being told
well you should eat this way or that way
and and I think that's I think it can be
a bit misleading but I think broadly
speaking it's a good thing that people
are thinking more about what they put in
their mouths and so a lunchtime they
don't just want to go and mindlessly go
down the sandwich shop and buy whatever
kind of first appeals to them Ramsden
snacks have to be tasty and suitable for
lunch breaks like avocado on toast with
green onions and lime pureed they have
to take no longer than 20 minutes to
make and keep in the fridge for at least
three days some of his snacks require
one last step just before eating a few
seconds in the toaster microwave or
electric kettle of the kind found in
most office kitchens Ramsdens idea is to
save money and time even the most exotic
dishes have to be easy to carry and
prepare as with all the recipes in the
book it's divided into what you can do
at home or what you need to do at home
what you put in your lunchbox and then
what you do at the office to finish it
off
his asian noodles are a perfect example
just add the curry paste brought from
home to the pre cooked noodles add hot
water and enjoy a meal of udon noodles
with miso and sesame
so many friends had already said to me a
board of going to the sandwich shop and
having the same sandwich and packet of
crisps and a drink and it's always so
expensive anglo-saxons have their
sandwiches and Germans have their dark
bread over half bring their lunch from
home but here to lunchtime habits are
changing many Germans are spending more
on food and drink I always take bread
slices from home and eat them at my desk
unfortunately as we don't bring anything
from home we go out to eat yeah we
always get something to go that's fast a
study has shown that Germans spend an
average of twenty minutes at lunch and
two-thirds of the British even less Anna
pinder in Naomi tweaked ins spotted an
opportunity here their startup lunch bxd
deliver such meals as quinoa salad with
orange and cabbage right to the desks of
London professionals the meals were
co-developed by nutritional consultant
and the menu changes weekly they're
packed into recyclable lunch boxes
bicycle couriers deliver them to as many
as 150 customers a day demand has been
growing steadily
it's a pretty massive market I think
especially at the moment with the like
everyone's very concerned about healthy
food and healthy living professionally
packed lunch boxes have a tradition in
other countries like India's Tiffin
boxes and Japan's bento boxes on the
internet taste is in the eye of the
beholder as Anna and Naomi well known we
got to try and make them interesting and
fun as well people so you put in
different snacks a every week we speak
two different snack companies and so
like this we've got the buttons music
yeah so they're like coconut milk
buttons made with raw cacao so it's kind
of like a healthy fun take on the sort
of things you get a lunch box when
you're younger such designer lunch boxes
don't come cheap but one can rest
assured that the veggies are fresh from
a London produce market and the herbs
from the company's own garden healthy
eating and quick cuisine are no longer
natural enemies